i might move to vegas what happened this
time you just see people and you're like
damn this this is like your
this is your loop like this is what you
do every day this [ __ ] is crazy here's
what was really fun was we go hang out
with their family do that all day and
then we go check in to our hotel like
pretty late we have ollie he's kind of
gone through it he's been pet by like a
hundred people maybe he just wants to
sit with us and relax but i'm like nah
come on i gotta i gotta play i gotta
play my slot okay so elena's like ah
aren't you tired i'm like i am but i
just we're here she's like we're not
really though i'm like no we're
literally here we're in vegas and the
machine is downstairs yeah yeah yeah get
in the elevator and we're thinking we'll
just be able to pop out pop back in and
you had ollie with you
we left him in the room okay okay yeah
no i put a cigarette in his mouth i was
like just
just sit here well daddy gets paid i
smoke a cigarette then i blows him in
his face
i'm playing and the machine kind of
feels like you know it's taking my money
i'm like [ __ ] you don't do this to me
the lady next to me she hits
like a jackpot nice yeah so then she's
hitting her bonus she's like taking
pictures landscape of her bonus nice and
then mine might start hitting i'm like
ooh
warming up yeah it was just yeah yeah
we're just warming up baby and i shoved
my whole arm and that cows no it started
to heat up and then we you know we made
some dollars and then elena's like we
should go i'm like nah it's starting to
heat up right now just like i [ __ ]
knew you were gonna say that because i
went down went down like a hundred i was
like this feels bad i should put another
hundred in here so i can make it back
right and i actually i did i made 180
bucks i was like whoa big [ __ ] so you
play long enough you make it back
everyone knows that's how gambling works
especially with slots it might take like
two decades yes but you get it back
you'll get it back you'll get it back
the trick to slots it was funny because
i started going down and then i told
elaine i'm like no you just go to a new
slot after you win she's like that
doesn't work i'm like watch i'm like
we're losing because i'm choosing to
lose slot machine thing to say exactly
this machine is clearly not hitting yeah
so we have to go to another one that
starts to hit are you with it yet yeah
are you stupid like are you dumb
so easy to understand this [ __ ] the
bonus the shell bonus is not a bonus
because it doesn't hit
jesus [ __ ] obviously augustus gloop is
the worst one so i took our cash out
voucher and we just started like
bouncing around just like making 15 at
each machine yeah we went back up to 100
she's like okay we're done we're done
that was great i was like no we're going
back to the cows went back to the cows i
lost it all when you play one machine
that doesn't hit you play three others
that hit the first one gets jealous it
gives you so it starts to hit again so
you gotta always go back to the first
one yeah it knows it's it knows i'm back
so it wants me to stay are you [ __ ]
stupid honey are you like are you a
[ __ ]
laughing your wife being completely
totally logical and yes it's just so
conscious
yeah exactly why are you going to
another machine oh my oh my god why
don't you just go back up to the room
why don't you just go watch tv maybe
that's easier for you to understand a
story or something this is so simple you
take the cash out voucher and you put it
in the other one and you hit again and
you take it out and then you hit on the
next one like oh did you even go to
school [ __ ] it's a cow
and a unicorn and an alien
in together one
try to keep up babe jesus christ i i
lost the most amount of money i've ever
lost on a sports bet and i just didn't
even watch the game i asked my friend
did we win he said nah i was like oh
holy [ __ ]
what am i doing what the [ __ ] i didn't
even watch it that's the whole point of
sports betting is you watch the game it
makes you more excited to watch the game
i didn't even know what time it was at
my friend's like you want in on this i
was like yeah put me in for this much is
this they were like jesus i was like
let's go
three hours later so what's going on
with the game oh we lost what game the
duke game oh yeah oh
second round of the acc tournament or
third i don't know well it seems like
coach k should be retiring then yeah
yeah
that was the one positive message i got
from last week's episode [ __ ] cody [ __ ]
duke [ __ ] coach kl yeah unc you got it
right noelle we did dance on that
motherfucker's grave and [ __ ] coach k's
family too yeah we had pictures of his
family that we were peeing on printed
out his family reunion photo we peed on
his whole bloodline dude they actually
put up a wall where anyone could public
piss yeah and we actually we laid one
down on this on the street it's a big
old tarp so women could pull up and just
crouch down and [ __ ] just fly yeah
and then we went to his house took a
[ __ ] on his front porch
lit on fire but that stinks
look dude it's your career dude tom
brady is back
yeah speaking of sports
[Music]
yeah that's a funny thing is that
somebody bought uh the retirement ball
for 500k and then tom brady was like
sorry now that person knows what it's
like to buy an nft yeah exactly rug pull
like a [ __ ] brady saw that [ __ ]
go for 500k he's like i can print more
of these yeah and then he just goes out
to the field
and thousand balls yeah like what the
what the [ __ ] dude what the [ __ ] that's
that's what remember loot loot the nft
project from dom the guy who started
vine
no he made this nft project like i mean
i guess earlier i was like a year ago
now and uh it was just like a list of
loot like sword like you know even sword
or whatever like right like shiny boots
that sort of [ __ ]
and the whole point was like developers
could build [ __ ] off of it right but
right away like dom is like the most i
don't know like sought after his
projects are the most sought after nft
projects for whatever reason because
he's always on the cutting edge of like
what's next right he's experiments a lot
with the technology right so he made
loot and right away they were worth like
15 eth or something like that like right
off the bat nice and people were
just paying out to ask for these things
but he doesn't believe in that sort of
stuff he'd rather take zero commission
and just push the technology forward
that's all he wants to do because he
really believes in it right so what he
did is he just came up with another
project called more loot with like a
hundred thousand of the same thing just
to tank the value of the
of the original set and so everyone was
pissed modern day robin hood dude yeah
but tom brady looked at his playbook and
was like
there's more loot 128 000 items that's
so funny to make some [ __ ] and go oh
you're you're gonna profit from this oh
no no that's not the point of this